isn't that what love is being fooled
like what why why are you not giving
much value to the emotional connection
with objects with with robots with
humans emotion is that thing which
happens when you're when you're
the uh
the func your expectation function is is
dashed and something else happens right
i mean that's what emotion is is that
what love is too yeah
you were expecting one thing and
something else happened yeah i don't
know i don't think that's true either
well what is it then i think no emotion
look i'm i'm sorry emotion is that but
but there's no i think love is just
fulfilling your purpose
no but okay i mean look like look like
whatever that means that's not i mean
really
so yeah okay so when are you happiest
it's like when you're all right all
right let me go back if you wanna if you
want me to follow your bliss let me
define love quickly okay go for it in
terms of assembly space right okay
excellent i didn't think i'd be doing
this today okay wait until assembly
theory 101 is taught and the second
lecture is assembly theory of love
actually but look but
it's being surprised the expectation is
being broken i'm just i'm not no go for
it i want to hear you i'm
but i would say so let's talk so we'll
talk about emotion but love is more
complex is love is a very complex set of
emotions together and logical stuff but
if you've got this
thing this person that's on this causal
chain
that has this empathy for this other
thing
love is being able to project ahead in
your assembly space
and work out what you're the person
you're in love with has a need for
and to do that for them without
selflessly
right because you can project ahead what
they're going to need and they are there
and you and maybe you can see someone is
going to fall over and you catch them
before they fall over or maybe you can
anticipate that someone's going to be
hungry and without helping you you just
help them that's right that just sounds
like empathy
but it's more complex than that right
it's more complex it's more about not
just empathy it's understanding it's
about kind of sharing that experience
it's an expression of love though that's
not what it's like to feel love like
feeling love is like
i i like i think it's like when you're
aligned with things that you feel like
are your purpose or your reason for
existing
so if you have those feelings
uh towards the robot
why is that rope i mean
because you said like the aj will build
an agi but it won't there'll be a
fundamental difference in aging well
build it it's gonna emerge from our
technology so i think you guys all are
doing the same thing i just said that
gpt that we do not correctly capture the
causal chain that we have within gpg
within i don't think it captures because
gpt3 is fundamentally trained
on a
corpus of knowledge
you know like the internet don't you
think it it gets better and better
better capturing the memory of all the
it will be better at fooling you and at
some point you won't care
but when it comes i my guess this is a
quick as i was getting to right before
we got i got in the love trap i love
trap yeah it was like
cronin in the love trap you know
sounds like a good fan that makes it sad
okay it's sad assembly space is sad no
um is that so sure but i think there are
other features that allow that we pull
on innovation that allow us to do more
than what we just see in gpt-3 so if
you're being fooled there so i think
what i mean is human beings have this
ability to be surprising and creative
whereas is it dali
this thing or or if you take um gpt3 is
not going to create a new verb
shakespeare created new verbs
you're like wow
and that required shakespeare to think
outside of language in a different
domain so i think having that
connections across multiple domains is
what you need for agi yeah but i don't
know if you need
um
i don't know if there's any limitations
gpt gpt
and
not being able to be across domain the
number one problem is um it's
instantiated in a resource limited
substrate um that we don't in silicon um
it is tr is tr the the architecture is
used for training for learning it is
about falling it's not about
understanding and i think that there is
some
understanding that we have that is not
yet symbolically representable language
learning language and using language
seems to be fundamentally about fooling
not understanding
why um why do you use language exactly
i'm i might disagree with that quite
fundamentally actually um but i don't i
i'm not sure i understand how to make a
coherent argument for that but my
feeling is
that there is
there are there is
comprehension
in reality in our consciousness below
language
and and we use those for language for
all sorts of expressions and we don't
yet understand that there's a gap we
will get there but i'm saying wouldn't
it be interesting it's a bit like saying
could i facsimile you or sarah into a
new human being right and and let's just
say i could copy all your atoms in the
positions of all your atoms the
electrons
into
into this other person they would be you
the answer is no and it's quite easy to
show using assembly theory because
actually the feature space you have that
graph the only way to copy you is to
create you on that graph so everything
that's happened to you in your past we
have to have a faithful record for if
you want another copy of lex you have to
do the exact thing one other copy sarah
another copy of lee the exact past has
to be replicated
you